una línea recta pasa por los siguientes
puntos el punto menos 36 y el punto 60
encuentra la ecuación de la línea en
enciso a la forma punto pendientes y
sobre la forma pendiente orden al origen
inciso sea la forma estándar y este
ejercicio me pareció bastante
interesante porque dice más o menos lo
siguiente que es una línea recta la
puedo escribir de las tres maneras
posibles así que vamos a recordar cada
una de estas maneras la forma punto
pendiente si nosotros tenemos un punto x
1 y 1 y este punto sabemos que está en
nuestra línea recta entonces podemos
escribir a la línea recta de la
siguiente manera yo ya que hay algo muy
importante casi siempre vemos ayer como
una función de x sin embargo aquí lo que
me estoy tomando es un punto particular
un valor que yo llamé c tanto de xy de
llegar a un punto que sé que está en mi
línea recta y siguiese este punto que
está en mi vida recta y ya también
conozco la pendiente entonces sé que la
forma punto pendiente de una ecuación de
una línea recta es esta de menos de 1 es
igual a m
aplica a x x 1 por ejemplo si en este
caso yo tengo a este punto de aquí y lo
quiero poner en ecuación de la forma
punto pendiente entonces aquí me
quedaría menos 6 es igual a m que
multiplica a x menos menos 3 x más 3
porque menos x menos me daría más bueno
ahora te vas a ver con mucha más
claridad cuando resolvamos este
ejercicio así que vamos a pensar en la
siguiente la forma pendiente ordenada al
origen y es igual a mx más ven esto lo
hemos visto varias veces donde m es la
pendiente y ve mi ordenada al origen o
donde interceptamos al eje de las 10 el
valor en donde interceptamos al eje de
la siesta y la forma estándar es la
forma x más bella igual hace aquí tengo
tanto los valores de x como los valores
de honor de la ecuación y el valor del
coeficiente libre del otro lado de la
ecuación así que bueno lo primero que
quiero hacer para resolver este problema
es algo muy importante es pensar en la
pendiente si yo sé la pendiente de esta
recta pasar de una forma a la otra va a
ser muy sencilla pues solamente vamos a
necesitar un poco de álgebra entonces
cuáles
de esta recta que tengo aquí la
pendiente que es igual a m es el cambio
entre el cambio en x delta day y entre
delta de x o como ya hemos visto varias
veces esto es exactamente lo mismo que
ye 2 - 1 entre x 2 - x 1 la diferencia
entre los valores de y entre la
diferencia entre los valores de x por lo
tanto voy a tomarme a éste como un punto
final y me queda que dos que es 0 -
lleva uno que es menos 6 entonces 0
menos 6 ya esto lo voy a dividir entre
x2 el cual va a ser 6 x 2 vale 6 que es
el valor de x en este punto final menos
x 10 x 1 vale menos 3 que es el punto
inicial fíjate bien este 0 va aquí y
entonces abajo tengo que poner su
correspondiente coordenada en x este 6
que tengo aquí es el valor del jet 1 y
abajo tenemos que poner su
correspondiente valor de x x 1 para que
no te confundas este otros 6 es este
otro 6 date cuenta que aquí tengo el
punto 6 0 6 en x 0
mientras que hay que restarle el valor
de x1 que es menos 3 es decir 6 menos
menos 3 donde menos 3 representa el
valor de x de este punto del punto menos
36 y bueno ya que tengo aquí todo con
orden ahora sí vamos a hacer la
correspondiente operación que tengo aquí
0 menos 6 es lo mismo que menos 6 déjame
ponerlo con este color será menos 6 es
menos 6 esta es la diferencia entre los
dos valores que tengo de jane y después
seis menos menos tres es lo mismo que 6
más 3 lo cual me da 96 menos menos 3 me
va a dar 9 que es la diferencia entre
los valores que tengo en x y me queda
menos 6 novenos pero menos 6 lo menos se
puede reducir si sacamos tercer arriba y
tercer abajo me quedan menos dos tercios
y perfecto ya tengo la pendiente una vez
que ya tengo la pendiente entonces no
voy a fijar en el inciso que dice
encuentra la ecuación de la recta en la
forma punto pendiente así que ya tengo
un punto ya tengo la pendiente
fácil encontrar esta forma punto
pendiente dejen ponerlo aquí punto
pendiente y bueno entonces tengo la
ecuación de menos de 1 es igual a m por
x menos x 1 menos yo no me voy a tomar
este punto lleva 1 vale 6 por lo tanto
va a ser 10 menos 6 esto tiene que ser
igual a la pendiente que vale menos dos
tercios de menos 6 es igual a menos dos
tercios que es la pendiente que
multiplica a x - x 10 x 1 es el valor de
x en este punto que estoy tomando en
este punto particular x menos menos 3 x
menos 3 y cabe mencionar que sería lo
mismo si tomara yo al otro punto lo
único que necesito es un punto que viva
en esta ecuación y no queda aquella
menos 6 es igual a menos dos tercios por
x menos x menos me da más por x más 3 y
aquí está ya tengo la primera respuesta
el inciso amp de esta pregunta ya tengo
la forma punto pendiente de esta recta y
bueno se más importante decirte de nuevo
que sirve de igual manera si tomamos al
otro punto
a ver el inciso b dice vamos a escribir
la ecuación de esta recta en la forma
pendiente ordenada al origen y bueno
para esto me voy a pasar en esta que ya
tengo aquí lo que voy a hacer es
distribuir este menos dos tercios y
despejar allí y me queda que ya menos 6
es igual a menos dos tercios por x es
menos dos tercios de x menos dos tercios
x y menos dos tercios más tres es más x
menos menos el 3 y el 3 se cancela y
solamente me quedan menos 2 y bueno aquí
lo que voy a hacer es sumarse este ambos
lados de la ecuación y me queda que aquí
le sumó 6 aquiles un 6 del lado
izquierdo se van a cancelar menos 6 + 6
y solamente me queda bien y del lado
izquierdo me queda menos dos tercios de
equis y después menos dos más seis lo
cual es cuatro positivos más cuatro y
igual a menos dos tercios de x más
cuatro es la solución del inciso b
porque fíjate que aquí ya tengo a la
pendiente la pendiente vale menos dos
tercios y además sabemos que intersecta
el eje de las guías en el valor de
cuatro así que vamos por la última
respuesta la respuesta del inciso sé qué
dice la ecuación en su forma estándar
y la forma estándar es x más bella igual
hacen por lo tanto que te va a parecer
si de esta misma ecuación en su forma
pendiente orden al origen yo paso a la x
del otro lado es decir lo que voy a
hacer aquí es sumar de ambos lados de la
ecuación más dos tercios de x entonces
más dos tercios de x y aquí más dos
tercios de x y lo que estoy haciendo es
que se cancele la x del lado derecho de
la ecuación y solamente me queda el
término libre y entonces me queda más
dos tercios de x más james déjame
ponerlo aquí a hoy creo que no me va a
caber aquí me va a caber más dos tercios
de x más james esto se pasa igual dos
tercios de x aquí le sumo y dos tercios
de x más bien estos dos valores se
cancelan menos dos tercios de x más dos
tercios de x se van y me queda del otro
lado 4 ya que ya lo tengo de su forma
estándar pero casi siempre se pone de la
siguiente manera para quitar este
quebrado que tengo aquí esto va a ser
exactamente lo mismo que si yo
multiplico todo por 3
recuerda que si lo que hago de un lado
lo hago del otro lado entonces la
igualdad se conserva entonces voy a
multiplicar todo por 3
para quitar esta fracción y me queda dos
tercios por 323 por james 37 y 3 por 4
12 y de esta manera ya se ve más clara
la forma estándar de esta ecuación pues
aquí ya no tengo fracciones y se ve
quién es a b y c